We are at war,
Captain Marvel
We need you
to save the world.
I want to do this.
It takes everything from me.
So we want to fight.
You can not protect your people.
Watch me.
We can't do this alone.
We need Captain Marvel.
You took everything from me,
and now I'm returning the favor.
That's not good news.
She's targeting every planet we call home.
We have to stop her. Together.
Higher.
Further. Faster.
The marvels.
I called a friend...
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
There's a bunch of new Marvel trailers
with a ton of new footage and Easter eggs,
so we'll break it all down.
They're teasing a big Thor cameo,
literally and metaphorically.
And we just learned
that Quasar was a big part of the movie.
So I'll explain how they're going
to include that character.
I know there's a bunch of questions
on top of all this stuff recently
because of the Marvel reboot talk
going around
unexplained, how that's going to affect
these characters after Secret Wars.
So if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
we're in the middle of the Loki season
two episodes right now.
I'm doing videos for all of them.
There's some loose connection
with what's happening in this during
Loki season two Doctor Strange
three in Avengers five, The Marvels
movie is supposed to go way deeper
into the concept of incursions,
which are leading up to Avengers
secret wars eventually.
I mean, it's a big part of Avengers
five two and Doctor Strange three,
but the whole idea is the different
universes are colliding with each other,
destroying one or each of them.
supposedly we're going to see one going
down during the events of this movie,
like they tried to stop one
from actually happening during the movie.
in it has something to do with DA Ben's
universal weapon
that he's using in combination
with the power of Ms..
Marvel's other bangle
the big Thor cameo everyone was talking
about recently in the footage.
Here is the end of the most recent trailer
Captain Marvel, Monica Rambeau, Ms..
Marvel, all fighting Da Bend the Army,
and it looks like they're in Earth's orbit
here.
I think this scene is meant to be
from like the big final battle.
I believe Da Ben brings her giant
universal weapon to earth
to retaliate against Captain Marvel
like a measure of last resort.
Like, Okay, fine.
We'll come to your home planet.
The movie is also going to explain where
Captain Marvel has been this whole time.
She's
basically been destroying the Kree left
and right increased rule space over here.
Like,
if you look at the map of the galaxy,
This is the part of space
she's been in most of the time
ever since the end of the first Captain
Marvel movie in the nineties.
That's why they call her
the Annihilator in the trailer,
which is obviously a nihilist reference.
But it is also a reference to her
basically annihilating their people.
there was a deleted scene
from the first Captain Marvel movie of her
killing the Supreme
Intelligence in its true comic book form.
This movie treats that like it was canon.
so I believe the idea
they're going with in
the movie is after the Supreme
Intelligence died in the nineties, Captain
Marvel went on a campaign of annihilation
to make more nihilist references,
destroying as much of the Kree's military
and civil infrastructure as possible,
bringing their entire race
to a standstill, like crippling them
almost to the point of extinction.
So they're kind of in the same spot
that the Skrulls
wound up in after the Kree scroll war.
Like basically their entire race
almost wound up dying out.
that's why the Kree hate Captain Marvel
so much when this movie picks up
That's what she means
when she says, You took everything for me.
Now I'm going to do it to you.
Speaking of Loki.
Connection to this is Zoe
Ashton playing Da band.
She's the leader of the Kree people.
When the movie picks up, she's also
in a relationship with Tom Hiddleston.
I don't know if they're engaged
or they're actually married,
but they just had a child together.
So there's like a big marvel family
developing here.
But at some point, the beginning
of the movie Da Ben finds Ms..
Marvel's bangle on this other point,
like you see them digging it up
and she adds it to her hammer here
she uses that power in combination
with the giant weapon.
And the weapon is designed
to steal the resources
from any planet in the galaxy
using these special portals.
I drink your milkshake.
I drink it up.
so she's trying to keep the Kree race
alive.
They're on life support,
basically stealing resources
they need from other planets.
And because the Kree hate Captain Marvel
so much for their currently,
they blame her for everything
that happened to their race.
They primarily target worlds
that she's friendly with or that
she's been to the last one
being the Earth itself.
Like there's been a bunch of footage
of them on Earth, but there's a little bit
that's why in all the trailers, you see
Nick Fury on his saber space station,
yelling at all the other workers,
calling them to battle stations
like they're in the middle of a full scale
Kree assault.
then I believe the idea
is that all three of them,
like Captain Marvel, Miss Marvel,
Monica Rambeau with Nick Fury,
the Saber Space station are not enough
to stop the army from destroying Earth
and taking its resources.
So as she says, she, quote unquote, calls
a friend who arrives using the Bifrost.
Normally when people see the Bifrost,
they think of the Thor character
because he can open bifrost portals
using stormbreaker.
But I actually think this is meant
to be the Valkyrie character
she calls from New Asgard, mostly because
they're doing the whole female team-up
thing in the movie,
and they use the A4 scene from Avengers
Endgame in the trailer.
They really want you to remember that
moment when she says she called a friend.
So who is the girl in that A4 scene
who typically would be using the bifrost?
It's Valkyrie.
now, the reason why Thor wouldn't
be around to help save Earth.
This is always a question.
Any time there's anything happening
anywhere near Earth, like
where are all of the Avengers characters
who are still alive right now?
Why are they not helping out?
Right now, mostly Thor is like in another
part of the universe with Gore's daughter
just saving random people,
trying to act like a God should act like
helping the people who are worshiping you
Now, if they hadn't left
at the end of that movie, to go do that
and that space version of the Winnebago,
like they went for Spaceballs
with the space Winnebago.
normally I would say Thor would be the one
to show up to help out.
He Captain Marvel also had that bro off
moment in Avengers
Endgame, where he basically told her
that they would be cool.
Unless there's, like, a special Thor cameo
at some point during Loki season two,
I don't think Chris Hemsworth's Thor
will come back until Avengers five.
all the Quasar stuff in the movie
was supposed to have been removed,
so it's like deleted scene status now,
but they were going to use flashbacks
with quasars character
at the beginning of the movie
to explain the true
origin of Miss Marvel's Bangles
because they were going to canonize them
as being based
on the quantum bands of Quasar in the Kree
nega bands.
the quantum bands in the Naga bands
are like two completely different things.
The quantum bands give the wearer control
over all electromagnetic energy,
and they draw power
from the quantum realm.
Thus the name quantum bands,
they can be used like Green Lantern rings
to create energy constructs.
The bands also gave Thanos parents
alarms and sweets and the ability
to conceive children,
which is how a couple of Eternals robots
on Titan can have biological children
answering the question.
Everyone wondered like,
How can Dinos have been born
if his parents were Eternals?
And all eternals are robots?
Maybe they'll get into that in
like some other Thanos related story.
Like there's a bunch of Eternals
related stuff
that they can do with Danson's character.
Much earlier in the timeline
when he was younger they tease his brother
at the end of the first Eternals
movie Eros.
So if they're going to be doing more
with his character
at some point in the future,
that would be the path to doing more.
Thanos stuff. In flashbacks.
The quantum bands are also supposed
to have been the prototype
for the Kree Naga bands, which are also
kind of like Green Lantern rings.
They allow you to turn mental energy
into physical form
so you create constructs
or give off energy blasts.
Kind of like you saw Ms.. Marvel
doing during the Ms..
Marvel series
apparently they would have shown
the original version of Quasar
at the beginning of the movie,
getting killed off
to show how he lost the two bangles.
In one, we end up on Earth in the Ten
Rings Temple at the beginning of the Ms..
Marvel series.
In the other
wound up in this distant planet.
James Gunn just introduced
the newer version of Quasar
in Guardians of the Galaxy three,
the Phyla-Vell version of the character.
final.
Phyla-Vell was important
because she was Quasar
during the Annihilation
Conquest storyline,
which is where this modern version
of the Guardians of the Galaxy team
that we see in the MCU came together
for the first time.
she also joined
the Guardians of the Galaxy team
in a later roster, just like Adam Warlock,
who was also in that Annihilation Conquest
storyline working with the Guardians.
fight.
Lavelle is also meant to be the daughter
of the original Captain Marvel Marvel.
So there's a connection to the Marvel
is through her character,
but as to me posting this video
I haven't seen the movie
so I don't know
if there are going to be any cameos
the big difference with her character
in this movie
is that she's obviously much younger.
And during that annihilation story,
she had already become Quasar
taking the Quantum
Bands usually you don't take the mantle
of Quasar until you're given the quantum.
Bands another big connection
to the Marvel's movie
through the Bangles and the Quantum bands,
they're meant to be relatively similar.
since they remove most of the Quasar stuff
from the Marvel's movie, we'll probably
see more quasar related stuff in future
space based movies.
Kevin Feige said that they'd be doing more
that recently, like more genres
which include more space based movies
besides Guardians of the Galaxy,
now the whole Marvel reboot thing
that's going down, all this recasting
talk is pretty simple for the characters
in the Marvel's movie.
It won't really affect them
that much or the plans that they have
for those characters,
with a few exceptions.
Maybe like we have a bunch of X-Men stuff
coming up,
we're going to pivot to X-Men stuff
after Secret Wars,
but like that's one of the reasons
why they just canonized Ms..
Marvel as a mutant, so she can crossover
with those X-Men stories.
like none of them are supposed
to be recast.
Like Brie
Larson could decide that she doesn't
want to make more Marvel movies
after Secret Wars.
That would be like the only character
that they would recast,
and that would be the only situation
where they do actually do that.
Monica Rambo is just going to continue
as per usual.
Ms. Marvel Like I said.
the way that Samuel L Jackson
talks about the future of Nick Fury.
He makes it sound like they'd like to pry
his gold dead hands off of his scripts
in Marvel movies
like they'll have to drag him
kicking and screaming
out of Kevin Biggie's offices
to keep him out of Marvel movies.
So unless he dies of natural causes,
he will just continue to be in
Marvel movies.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
If we see any more big Easter eggs
or anything else, I'll do more videos
for the Marvel's movie,
but my Paul Loki Season two Episode
three Video We'll post on Friday
just like normal.
Click here for that onto the link
as soon as I post that and click here
to learn about the big Marvel reboot.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!